[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHANGDRA RAM: I'm
someone who, I think,
always just grew up
loving two things--
that was food, and magazines,
and books, so food and writing.
And so I wound up--
I'm the Editor of "Plate," which
is a food magazine for chefs.
But it seems like a very
well thought-out plan,
but I did study
journalism in undergrad,
and did a lot of
writing in that time.
And then I kind of
said, well, screw it.
I'm going to go to
culinary school.
And I'm going to
go all in on that.
So I went to New York to the
Culinary Institute of America,
and worked for a caterer there
doing all kinds of events.
And she had a
prepared food store.
And that was exactly
what I wanted to do.
And thank god I worked for her.
So I learned that that
was exactly what I did not
want to do.
And so I cooked in restaurants
and did some consulting,
culinary consulting work,
and then found my way back
into writing, and so was
working as a freelance food
writer, and kind
of happily being
able to provide this perspective
of what it's like to cook
and to work in restaurants.
And then with
"Plates", since we're
a food magazine for
chefs, it works out,
because I'm able to
better understand
what chefs are going through,
what they're looking for,
the difference between avocado
toast as a trend for consumers
as opposed to what they want to
have in the kitchen that works.
And then I get to hang out
with cool people like Bill.
BILL KIM: And she travels how
many days out of the year?
Probably like 200.
CHANGDRA RAM: Well, and
actually, the genesis
of this book took place on a
bus in the middle of nowhere
in Australia, somewhere
between, I don't know--
BILL KIM: Brisbane
and Melbourne, right?
CHANGDRA RAM: Yeah, somewhere
between Brisbane and Melbourne,
Bill and his wife, Yvonne,
joined me on a trip
to learn all about Australia.
I was asked to bring
some chefs there.
So that's when the-- that was
like the germ of the idea.
So--
BILL KIM: Here we are.
CHANGDRA RAM: How about you?
BILL KIM: Me?
So my journey
started from Korea.
I was-- I moved here when
I was seven, not by choice.
My parents wanted to give
us a better quality of life,
so we moved.
And the thing that I ask my
parents, like, why didn't when
we, when we had the
layaway in LA and Hawaii,
why did we not stop at
those places and live there?
So we ended up here
in 1977, in Chicago,
with the blizzard in February.
So that was my harsh
reality, that I
was going to live here, and
be here for probably, what,
30 years, growing up, going
to grade school, high school.
Went to two culinary schools.
I was fortunate enough I
found something I really
love to do at a very early age.
And I really wanted to learn
the foundation of cooking,
which was not Korean back then.
It was French cuisine.
So I spent my time learning
about the foundation
of cooking, then
took me to Atlanta,
worked for a French
gentleman down there.
Then I came up for Chicago,
because I missed home deeply.
I'm a huge sports fan, and
I know today's draft day.
So we have to make sure that
the Bears pick the right person.
I had two people that
I went to go spend
a day, or trail, or shadow.
And they both kind of
pointed at this restaurant.
It was at a townhouse.
It was 816 West Armitage.
And it was a restaurant
called Charlie Trotter's.
And basically, both of these
chefs had their own restaurant,
but they said if I were you,
I would go to this restaurant.
And I had no clue what this
restaurant's all about.
But when I got there,
my world really
changed, and really helped
propel me to what I know now.
Because it really-- that was
the focal point of cuisine
back in the early '90s.
I was fortunate
enough to be there
for about three and a half
years the first time around.
And we were voted the number
one restaurant in the country
back then.
We had a table in the kitchen.
We had a $250,000
Rolls-Royce of a stove
that was one piece, that
was built in Lyon, France.
You could eat food off
the floor, if it need be.
Every hour within
the hour there's, we
call it a sweep and a mop.
And basically, we would have
the new recruits or new cooks
that came in, basically, how
you handled the mop and a broom
would tell you how
that person works.
That was an inside
joke between all of us.
But that really made me
see outside of Chicago.
So I got to travel.
I got to eat it three-star
Michelin restaurants.
I was 26.
I didn't know.
I had-- I tell
Chandra all the time--
one sport jacket, not a suit.
I had one sport jacket.
And Charlie said, I think you're
going to need a couple more,
because we're going to go and
do a book signing in France,
meet the French media,
go to Switzerland.
And I've never traveled
outside of Chicago.
And when I came back,
I knew I had to leave.
I had to see different
parts of the world.
So I left for 10 years
on the east coast,
and got to experience it.
But same thing happened,
where I missed home again.
This time, for 10
years, I had my watch
and my clocks set on Midwestern
time-- never changed it.
And I knew I was going
to come back home.
And I came back.
My second tour of
duty at Trotter's, I
was named the chef de cuisine.
But it wasn't the same.
It wasn't that tunnel-vision
kid 10 years ago working there.
And I'd seen the world.
And I'm just, like, I
have to open my own place.
And when it was time for me
to do that, it wasn't what
I was trained to do.
I wanted to do something
that was more meaningful,
which meant wanted to
do food that was closer
to me, who I was as a person.
My family owned dry cleaners.
I always say dry cleaners,
but they only owned one.
My parents washed people's
clothes for 35 years.
And I seen how hard they worked.
So I always told myself,
if I got educated here,
did something that
I really wanted
to do, there's no way in hell
I was not going to succeed,
because they did something
they didn't want to do.
They sacrificed for us.
So that was a synthesis of us.
We said, we will
build this restaurant,
and we will make it work.
And the irony is, when we
built the first restaurant
of our own, it was
in a strip mall--
dry cleaners and a laundry mat.
So we were in 1,000
square-foot place.
And we opened in 2008,
so it's been 10 years.
But the economy was
going like this.
All the people that
I have worked with
or my friends who have
the higher end restaurant,
they were suffering,
because it was that time.
And I really thought
the market was missing.
You had the high
end places, and you
had the fast-food
restaurants, but there
was nothing in between.
I'm just, like, why can't food
not be expensive, but still
be really, really good?
And that's when we
opened up Urban Belly.
It's counter service.
Nothing's over $13.
And we basically said,
if it's flavorful,
it's accessible, affordable
to everybody, hey,
if I fail on that, I'm OK.
Because when we first--
when we opened up that
restaurant, I'd lived my dream.
That was everything
that I could wish for.
And I always tell somebody, if
I get hit by a car tomorrow,
I lived my dream.
So then on top of
that, we opened up
Belly Shack, then bellyQ.
We have our sauce line.
Now we have a book.
I mean, I pinch
myself every day,
because it's all the things
I've thought about doing.
And were actually doing it.
And with her help, I
mean, with my wife's help,
it's just I surrounded
myself with ladies of power.
And it's just like I just
have to just kind of dream,
and think, and they
did do the pushing.
And they've done very well.
SPEAKER: So when you talk
a little about the impetus,
and your background, one
thing I was curious about
is what inspired you,
even at the beginning
and as you were growing up,
that gave you that passion
to go after going
to culinary school,
just at the starting point?
BILL KIM: Well,
when you're young,
especially when you're
from another country,
you just want to fit in.
I had a Korean name.
It was very hard to pronounce.
And I was--
I knew when B came
around in the alphabet,
I'm just, like, oh, I need
to go hide, because they're
going to make fun of you.
So--
CHANGDRA RAM: You
have to tell them.
BILL KIM: It's Bum-Suk.
Then my brother's first
name is Yoo-Suk, so Yoo-Suk,
or you suck--
I mean, that was just--
it was so, like, come on.
CHANGDRA RAM: Bill told
me this the day before we
had to turn in the manuscript.
And I was, like,
oh, my god, I have
to go back and rewrite the
entire introduction just
so we can get this in.
But it's such a
universal experience.
If you have a name that's
reflective of another country,
you totally remember being
a little kid in school,
knowing, OK, yeah, my
name's about to come up,
and they don't
know how to say it.
BILL KIM: Yeah.
CHANGDRA RAM: I don't
know how you did it.
BILL KIM: So the reason
why we did the restaurant
that we were so driven to do,
because for selfish reasons,
I wanted a restaurant
of both cultures.
I wanted-- I didn't want to eat
rice three times a day, which
was what I was
accustomed to doing.
And I used to go
every Friday, I would
go to my friend's,
Joe McDermott's house,
because I knew every Friday
was pizza at their house.
So I loved that.
And I used to go to
Tony Bruno's house,
because I knew it was Prince
spaghetti day on Wednesday.
And I knew what I
was going to get.
At my house, you never knew
what you were going to get,
because we probably ate the
leftovers from the two days
before.
So you're eating the
same thing all the time.
So as we thought
about what it meant
to open up your
restaurant, I think
this is something that a lot of
the chefs sometimes miss out.
It's not the concept.
It's who you are as
a person, and how
you want to express
yourself in the food.
That's being genuine.
It's not the concept.
It's not how well
you could cook.
Like, what's from
your heart, and you've
got to let that show
on the plate of food
that you're cooking.
So what we are cooking when
we opened up the restaurant,
it's all the things
that I wanted to eat.
It's what we prepared at home.
But I wanted to elevate it.
Like, my mom used
to do fried rice,
but she made it with Crisco.
And she used 10 pounds of rice.
And we had it for
months in the microwave.
And we would take it out.
And we used to have a stick,
because there is tons of Crisco
there.
So we said we're going
to do fried rice.
But we also made dumplings
at the house, so we did--
we're going to
elevate the dumplings.
And the dumplings are going to
be five different skins, five
different unique flavors.
Then on top of
that, Urban Belly,
people call it a ramen shop.
But if you really
look at our menu,
we only have one damn ramen.
So no, it's not a ramen shop.
It's a noodle shop with five
different kinds of noodles.
Because it takes-- to me,
when you go spend the time,
and learn some of the
things that I did,
it's easy to just do ramen.
But when you start putting
rice cakes, rice noodles, udon,
chow fun, it's all these
things that it's there.
It's for you to kind of go,
and put some skills in there,
and make it tasty.
So it's for selfish reasons.
So we did something
that I love eating.
But we wanted to elevate it.
So competition-wise,
I didn't want
people to be able to
do some of the things,
because I have a
different experience
than a lot of the
other shops in Chicago,
and wanted to kind
of put our stamp,
and I wanted to bring to
the city something totally
different that people
are not accustomed to.
SPEAKER: Knowing you
spent time in fine dining,
working for Charlie
Trotter, and knowing
there's lots of alumni
of Charlie Trotter who
have gone on in Chicago
to start restaurants,
how would you say being from the
Midwest, and your wife's Puerto
Rican descent, how
that has influenced?
Because it is very genuine.
We've been to the restaurant.
We've tasted a lot of the food.
And it feels so natural.
it's truly amazing.
But what was that
process like, even
just starting the
restaurant, and making
that move to Urban Belly?
BILL KIM: Yeah, I think the
thing that we kept on saying,
we want to start taking away.
Less is more, which meant
when you work in fine dining,
there there's a lot of layers
of the hierarchy, who's who,
and who has
seniority, or we need
to have this type of service.
We just said, you know what?
You come, free parking.
You don't have to pay
for alcohol because it's
BYOB five years ago.
And you see the menu.
You order.
We just took all the
things out of dining,
what people understood.
And it was basically to
primitive-- here's food.
You pay.
You order.
We're bringing you the food.
And that was it.
If you don't like it, too bad.
But it was all
about giving it back
to the customers, which meant
you don't have to valet.
You don't have to tip
if you don't want to.
And here it is.
Here's the food, and this
what we're going to do.
You're going to
get great service.
I always said you could do two
things-- you could say thank
you and hello to a customer.
That costs nobody any money.
If we could do that,
that's something
that anybody could do.
And going into the
culture of my wife and I,
it's all natural, because
we always like this--
when we do food,
we like to say we
like to tell the love
story through food,
which means when I met my
wife, I'd never had plantains.
But when I had it,
I'm just, like, wow.
How can I put this into my food?
And I wanted to not
because she's my wife.
It's something that
I've never had.
So we do a dish at bellyQ now.
It's called mofongo.
So it's plaintains that is
boiled instead of fried.
So I try to take the dish apart.
First, the traditional way
is you take pork skins,
chicharrones.
You take garlic,
almost like a mojo.
And you just smash
it until you just
get this mashed plantation.
Changdra hates this, but
I use tofu cream cheese.
That is something
that I like using,
because it adds richness,
without being super heavy.
Then instead of
adding chicharrones,
we add crispy tortillas.
Then we add our version
of chimichurri or mojo.
Then we make this, like, mashed
plantation with chimichurri,
so it has the flavor of mofongo.
It's not traditional,
but on top of that,
we add kimchi salsa
on top of the--
I call it mashed plantains.
So it kind of gives you a kick.
But it all goes well together.
Because we don't just say this
is what we're going to do.
We actually taste it, make
sure it goes well together.
Then we serve pork
and plantation chips.
So it's a harmonious
way of doing it.
But my wife definitely has
an influence on my cooking,
and I kind of have influence
on her of cleaning.
But she won't let me
clean up the house.
She's, like, no, you cannot
use this sponge for this.
I'm just, like, come on.
Just let me clean.
She won't let me do it.
I always tell her before
she goes shopping,
you've got to take an
inventory of cleaning products.
Because she always buys
double of everything.
Stop.
It's not going to go bad.
You've got to take
inventory before you go.
SPEAKER: Cleaning products
are definitely important.
I'm thinking about that
in my own home life,
and yeah, the sponge
struggle is real, very real.
So tell us a little bit
more about the book.
Just in describing the food,
I think a lot of our mouths
are watering.
And just a quick note for
everyone here, our happy hour,
our IFFY event
afterwards, we're actually
going to have some
dishes from the book.
So save room.
But that in mind, tell
us a little bit more
about the book and the process.
BILL KIM: Changdra.
CHANGDRA RAM: Well, the
book came together really
as a reflection of a lot of
what Bill's been talking about,
which is how he
runs his restaurant.
And so when we first sat down
and started talking about this,
he said, look, here's
what I want to do.
Bill trained in French kitchens.
I went to culinary
school when it
was kind of all French, all
sort of old-school European.
And so we're both very
used to the idea of mother
sauces, these
sauces that you use,
and you just create variations.
And that's how you
make everything
in classical French cooking.
He created the master
sauces for Korean barbecue.
And so it's seven different
sauces and three spice rubs.
And you create those.
I have tubs of them in my--
small, little tubs of them
in my freezer.
And I just make them,
throw them in there.
And then when I want
to make something,
I just pull out, OK, I
need half a cup of this.
I need three tablespoons
of that, mix them up.
So you take these seven
sauces, three spice rubs,
use them all sorts of
different combinations.
And that's how you make
everything in the book.
So it's how he runs
his restaurants.
It's incredibly efficient.
It allows people
who maybe don't have
a ton of culinary
experience, training,
it allows them to learn
a skill, because it's
very easy to do that.
But it's also really cool,
because so many people--
it's only been a week
since the book came out--
but so many people are,
like, this is so easy.
I cannot believe on a Tuesday
night I'm actually able to make
this food.
And one thing I really love
about it is all of the things
that Bill was talking about,
like going to hang out with his
Italian friends after school
or having a Puerto Rican wife,
and I think more importantly,
a Puerto Rican mother-in-law--
BILL KIM: Yes, my
wife doesn't cook.
CHANGDRA RAM: That's
why she married you.
BILL KIM: Yeah.
CHANGDRA RAM: But all
of those influences,
time working at Charlie
Trotter's, his time
working for Jean Banchet in
Atlanta, all those things
come through in the book.
So you see there's a sauce
we called a Korican sauce.
And it's his Korean/Puerto
Rican master sauce that you use.
And you can mix it up.
And you can use it on
any kind of protein.
We did that with a
turkey and with the pork,
I think, in the book.
And so it's really
cool to just see
all these different
flavors, and see
how Bill's experience traveling
to a different country
would yield a new
sauce that you combine
in a ton of different ways, and
make all these great dishes.
And then you combine
everything again,
and you make-- we have an
entire chapter on leftovers.
Because we're both Asian,
and we do not waste food.
BILL KIM: How to
Kung Fu it, right?
CHANGDRA RAM: Yes.
SPEAKER: I might have to ask
you more about that in a minute.
I have to say that
for me personally,
I don't do a lot of
cooking in the home.
I think there are
some people here
who might be able
to attest to that.
And when looking at the recipes,
they seem very accessible.
And being in
Chicago, the weather
is finally getting better.
People are beginning to consider
dusting off their grills, which
is pretty exciting.
And we want to put them to use.
Could you maybe tell us a little
about your favorite dishes
from the cookbook, or just
go-to things when for you
personally, when
you're in a hurry,
or when you want to
entertain people, things
you like to cook?
BILL KIM: A personal
favorite in the recipe--
it's like, what is
your signature dish?
Well, the story that I love--
when we were young, we
couldn't afford a grill.
And the public parks, it's
called "forest preserves"
in Chicago.
So they would have free grills.
So we would go as a family
on Sundays after church.
And we would go have
one of those grills.
And we put charcoal in there.
And as soon as we put
the meat on that's
been marinating overnight,
it's one of the recipes,
and strangers would
come, because they would
smell the Korean barbecue.
And that's one of the moments
in my life that I remember.
Because now, it breaks
down barrier who
you are, what color you are.
It's food.
And it just opens the gateway
to people trying something new
in somebody else's culture.
So that's, like, wow.
That was the moment.
And just doing this kind of
food, it's easy, accessible.
And I think a lot of times when
people are cooking Asian food,
they're so intimidated.
So we made it very simple for
people to go get ingredients.
And the last week,
I've been getting
videos and Instagrams of
people actually cooking out
of the book.
So there's moments
where I'm, like, not--
it's supposed to be
Korean chili flakes,
not chili flakes that you put.
So that's like triple
the spice it needs.
But you know what it is?
We have to all understand
that now more than ever,
there is no border
around what we do.
So we like to say we're
cooking without borders,
which means you don't have to
be an expert, but I studied it.
I wanted to do this.
But always, when you're in a
category, when we first opened,
people were, like, what
category do you want to be in?
Is it Korean?
Is it fusion-- and I hate the
word, "fusion," because, ugh.
Let it be.
It could be Asian.
And it could be
influences from all over.
Because it really-- when I
look at Mexico, what they have,
and what's in Asia--
a water chestnut doesn't
have to be canned.
But what can you find,
something that's here,
that's similar in texture?
So I look to Latin
cuisine, you have jicama.
And you get that same texture.
And then you can go either way.
And we use chili in
both parts of the world.
Cilantro is called coriander.
So you could do that all over.
And that's what draws
the inspiration for me
to find the commonality
in all the cultures,
and put it in our food.
And hopefully, this
year, me and my wife
will get to go to Greece,
which I've never been to.
But I know I'm going
to find something there
that I'm going to
bring back, and it's
going to go into my food.
Because olive oil, limes,
lemons, things like that,
those are haunting flavors
that I like to use in my food.
SPEAKER: So we talk
about connectedness
and how you're creating
food without borders,
technology is also a big factor
in breaking down barriers.
And would be curious, both from
the perspective of the book
and also from the perspective
of your business as a chef
and as a business owner, how
technology has helped you.
So it's really a
loaded question.
But maybe we can start with
the book and the collaboration.
CHANGDRA RAM: Well,
for the book, I think--
we were laughing.
We're like, oh, I don't
even know how we--
we would still be
working on this book
if we had not been able to
take advantage of technology.
Because as Bill said, I
travel a lot for the magazine,
but I'm also someone
who can and absolutely
loves working on airplanes.
So I needed to be
able to do that.
But we're two people
who live in Chicago.
We're working on
this in Chicago.
Our editors and the whole
production team and design
team at Ten Speed
Press are based
in Emeryville, California,
but the creative director
was based in Santa Barbara.
Johnny Autry, our
amazing photographer,
is based in North Carolina.
So we were utterly dependent
on Google Docs and Forms.
So thank you.
You are overlords, and we
appreciate what you've done.
But that was how we
organized everything.
We had two recipe testers
working and testing recipes.
And I could be on an
airplane, looking at the notes
that they put on after
testing a recipe,
and then I could input
comments, and not lose any time.
When we did our photo
shoot, we had a spreadsheet
uploaded so that the editorial
and design team in California
could see what we were
working on every day.
And then every night,
our photographer
was able to upload the photos
just so they could see.
They could not have to worry
about flying out to Chicago,
but they could be
there, and see what
was happening with the
photography, how things were
looking, and even
say, hey, think
about doing some of these
for backgrounds and that.
And that could be
the creative director
dropping her daughter off
somewhere and taking a look.
So that was amazing.
And then the thing
that other people
who coauthor
cookbooks with chefs
always grit their teeth about,
because they can't believe
it was so easy,
was the fact that I
wrote the book with a
chef who understands
how to upload to Google Docs.
So a friend of mine
coauthored a book with a chef.
And he had to literally sit
across the table from him,
and drag every ingredient
out one at a time.
And he was, like,
yeah, we used to sit
from 5:00 in the afternoon
until 2:00 in the morning
every single Monday to do that.
And I was like, oh, yeah, Bill
just uploaded all the recipes.
It was fine.
So yeah, I mean, I
think that we wrote this
in a very short amount of time.
And I think that it was only
possible because of that.
And then I mentioned to
you before, my husband Jay
is a product manager.
And so he has taken
it even further,
and now creates spreadsheets
that indicate with formulas
in there that indicate
how far along are you
in the process of
creating each recipe?
And how many days
behind are you,
which is really the worst thing
you can ever do to your wife.
Don't ever do that.
But then the restaurant,
you've got the place--
I mean, you've got the
place set up for efficiency.
BILL KIM: Yeah.
So we just held a smart
class this morning.
So it's our second time around.
We try to bring technology
into our kitchen,
so we are Wi-Fi and
Bluetooth connected
in our kitchen, which is crazy.
So I could see on my phone if
somebody's using the oven right
now, at what temperature.
And now--
CHANGDRA RAM: Now you're
the creepy overlord.
BILL KIM: Yeah.
And with the phone,
and also, now,
with Wi-Fi built into the
ovens, so basically now,
we download the picture
of the finished product.
Let's say you're charring
broccoli in the oven.
So now, they have ovens
where you could put dry heat
and humidity at the same time.
So you could do
70% dry, 30% steam.
And you could cook in there.
And basically, the
finished product comes out.
We take a picture,
download that to the oven.
And now a prep cook that just
starts, they just have to say,
"Broccoli," show a picture.
Now you don't need to remember
temperatures or settings.
Now, you just press the
picture of the broccoli.
You could also, if you're taking
something out of the freezer,
let's say, and you
put it into this--
it's called the blast chiller.
Take it, set it
on thaw overnight.
And you don't have to run water.
You're wasting water,
wasting energy.
And basically, when
you come the next day,
you take it from
the frozen stage.
Then it thaws it out,
and you're ready to go.
So you're not wasting time.
You could also what's
called "proofing."
You could actually make bread.
Then you could shock-freeze
it at negative 40.
So it doesn't kill the
yeast, but it freezes it.
Then two days later,
you could take it out
before you go home, let it proof
very slowly, relax the dough.
So a person coming the next
day could actually take it
as soon as they come in.
They could bake off the bread,
which sometimes could take up
to two or three hours in a
busy kitchen, to take up space.
So there's also a
controlled vapor cooking,
which is basically, if you're
making grits or polenta,
there's a point where
when you're cooking it,
it has this like splatter
thing that happens.
And it's like almost
getting hit with heat.
You almost need a visor,
like a welding helmet,
because the things
just kind of bubble.
So this controlled
vapor cooking,
you just bring it up to a boil.
Then you cover it.
Just put it in
basically an oven.
It's controlled
atmosphere of cooking.
Two hours later, it's
completely cooked.
So what it does is first,
it gives the person
that's actually
cooking it complete
control of the product.
And also, it gives that person
time to do other things.
So you don't have to
keep an eye on things.
It's like the Instapot,
everybody is going--
so we have an Instapot
kind of thing,
where if you have a braised
short rib that you want to do,
we could put it in before we
go home, next morning come,
and hold it at the
same temperature.
It's completely cooked.
So there's the efficiency of us
cooking while we're not there.
And it's not by heat.
It's by electricity.
And it's controlled
100%, and it's done.
And what that does
is I can hire people
that need a career out of it.
They don't need to be chefs.
They just need a job.
And we have people
who want a job.
They want to go home
at a certain time.
They have kids.
They have other responsibility.
Now we can teach them a skill
that they could provide us.
Because not everybody
is aspiring to be chefs.
And we could give people
a chance that might not
have a chance in life.
So these are things
that we put in place
so we could hire more people.
SPEAKER: Earlier, we were
talking about your experience
working with Charlie Trotter.
And one of the things I think we
mentioned before the interview
was around how he gave
back to the community.
And what you're describing
here, using technology
and using these
efficiencies in the kitchen
to provide
opportunities to folks--
tell us a little more about
how you've been involved
in the community in Chicago.
BILL KIM: Sure.
I think going back, I
think a lot of people
think what I've learned
there at Charlie Trotter,
it was, yes, about cooking.
But it was more, I'd
learn taking away,
the greatest thing
ever is to give back.
Charlie used to invite
14 students four times
a week in his test kitchen
from all different parts
of the Chicago land area.
They would get the same meal
as paying guests that night.
And all of us people
in the kitchen,
we'd have to come and explain
the definition of excellence.
But they would get exactly
what people were eating.
And now, it opened doors to
kids that maybe would not get
a chance to eat and talk to--
Charlie didn't want
them to be chefs.
He just want-- he wanted people
in different neighborhoods,
and usually it was an
underserved neighborhoods,
to get to kind of dream
outside where they live.
And now, some of the
charities that we work with
is Greater Food Depository.
My wife is just on the
board called "Rock Passage."
So it's taking kids
who've been in gangs,
and giving them opportunities
to come to the real world,
and be able to function.
Common Threads, the after-school
program for kids under 12,
Meals on Wheels, which Changdra
put together every year.
And I just like to be
part of a community.
Even when my mom, she
had her dry cleaners,
she always bought something
from the neighborhood.
It was usually when
the government cheese--
when it was there, we would have
slices of cheese at our house
all the time, even though
I was lactose intolerant.
We would always have
a thing of cheese.
And she would support
the community,
even though we
didn't live there.
She would always purchase
that every month.
So for us, obviously,
we're in the West Loop.
I live in Pilsen.
But we do a thing
every year, and we
don't like to put it out there.
We call Chefs Giving
in East Garfield Park,
Inspiration Kitchen--
that's really one charity
dear to my heart.
It's a job training
program for homeless.
And we take people who are
artists, some of my friends,
chefs, authors, writers.
And two weeks
before Thanksgiving,
we will do this, like, gourmet
spread for homeless people.
And it's not like--
it's actually like
truffle mac and cheese,
where we're doing
coconut gravy, turkey.
And we're doing it free.
We pay for all of it.
But we want the people
in the neighborhood
to eat something that is not--
and it's from our
restaurant, some of us.
Some people cook at home.
And we don't tell everybody.
We only tell people
in the neighborhood,
and it's a mile and a half from
where we are in the West Loop
to go to East Garfield Park.
SPEAKER: So right
now, we're opened up
to the audience for questions.
There is a microphone back here.
So if you have questions,
please use the mike.
AUDIENCE: Now with social media,
everybody is a food critic.
I was just curious about
what the role of social media
plays in the
decisions you make as
far as ingredients or new
menus, or even just your mood.
BILL KIM: So I think 2008,
when we first opened, we had--
and Alisa, you're
going to cringe--
we had no PR, no
marketing, no plans of it.
Our very first customer,
very first customer, and we
were told this to Monica when I
saw her last week, Monica Eng.
She was a "Tribune" food
writer, one of the food writers
at the "Chicago Tribune."
So she was our very
first one customer.
Our third customer was Steve
Dolinsky, The Hungry Hound.
He does a feed podcast.
He was number three.
So they're the ones
who kind of blasted off
through social media.
Then Twitter, then
the food forums,
they blasted it off to eight
or nine months later, we
got voted top 50
restaurants by what was it?
One of the major magazines.
I totally forgot.
But--
CHANGDRA RAM: "Food and Wine?"
BILL KIM: Not "Food and Wine."
It was Travel and Leisure.
So we're in the
company of those,
out of those top 50 in
the country, one was us,
the other one was Publican.
The other one was [INAUDIBLE]
So not knowing the power
of social media back then,
I was very ignorant, and just
wanted to cook good food.
But as we move forward,
it's utmost important.
Every day, I wake up
to what's called Venga.
And it goes out into space,
the internet or the interweb.
And I get alerts on my phone.
And I wake up to it, and
see what's out there.
Alisa, who is our marketing
manager for Cornerstone,
she's here.
And I talk to her probably
more than my wife,
and seeing what we
do, how we do it.
It's a strategy.
It really is.
And food is a given.
Now we have to be able
to have people know
what it is that we're doing.
But it is right up there,
probably as more important.
Because I believe food
should be a given.
There should be
that's a standard.
Than everything else
we have to work at,
and social media is right there.
CHANGDRA RAM: And
we learned so much
about what people wanted in a
cookbook from reading reviews.
So I would-- you know when you
wake up at 4:00 in the morning,
you're a little freaked
out about everything
you've got going on?
I would do exactly what
you're not supposed to do,
which is I would grab my phone.
And I started reading Amazon
reader reviews, reviews
on Food52, see what people were
saying about different grilling
books, about Korean books,
about cookbooks in general,
and what kind of
issues they had.
One of the things I
really love about our book
is the fact that the recipes
for those seven sauces
and the three spice rubs,
which are all very short,
they were printed on
the inside back cover.
And that was a thing
I kept bringing up,
because on Food52, so many
people commented about how they
hated having to flip back
and forth in a cookbook
to find, oh, god,
there's a subrecipe.
And it's on Page 36.
And now I've got
to find Page 36.
And then I've got to
go back to Page 79
to find the original recipe.
So we kept working.
It was a thing that we
brought up from the get-go
with our editor.
And Kelly, and Lizzie,
and Emma, the design team,
they kept kind of figuring out,
saying, OK, well, maybe we'll
do a big pull-out.
And I was, one day, what if we
have different colored ribbons?
And then she just texted
me back, and said,
who's going to pay for that?
And I was, like, OK.
So then I came up with this
idea to print these base recipes
on the inside cover, so you
don't have to flip around.
You can find them.
But that's something
I wouldn't have known,
we wouldn't have known, to
even ask for and really push
for had we not seen the
complaints on social media.
So sometimes, it is
for good and not evil.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Thanks for coming.
I have a couple of questions.
The first one is, how do
you choose a recipe tester?
And how much
influence do they have
over the direction of the book?
CHANGDRA RAM: I mean, we
were fortunate to have
very good friends who were
starting a business where
they were testing recipes.
But it's also equally
important to send the recipe
to someone who doesn't know
you, ideally someone who doesn't
really know how to cook.
That's--
AUDIENCE: I volunteer
as [INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHANGDRA RAM: OK.
AUDIENCE: Just in case you
ever need someone in future.
CHANGDRA RAM: Because you
want to know how someone--
I mean, if Bill
hands me a recipe,
I have known him and his
food for years, and years,
and years.
And I cooked in restaurants.
And so I will--
someone who's very
well trained will
start to automatically
fill in the blanks.
But you want
someone to say, hey,
you've got me soaking
rice, and then cooking it.
Am I cooking it in the
water I'm soaking it in?
Or am I adding fresh water?
And someone asked that question.
I was, like, I would
never have thought,
OK, now we're
adding that back in.
BILL KIM: And it
was important for us
that people were using
a residential stove.
Because obviously,
our commercial stuff
is probably three
times as powerful.
So it was very
important that they were
using that type of equipment.
And also, we were
fortunate enough to--
our recipe testers,
one of them had kids,
which I wanted to have,
because I would only
cook for two at the house.
And Changdra also.
So there was going
to be leftovers.
How they were going to use it?
And they're, like,
the kids don't
want to eat that broccoli
anymore, because they've
been eating it for days.
But we knew for six people,
this will be this much.
And the thing that
we also wanted was we
wanted all the ingredients to
be accessible to the grocery
store, not specialty markets.
Because I think that's
another thing that I read,
that people just didn't want
to go to five different places
to get things for the recipe.
So it was very, very
important for us
to be accessible to a
whole realm of people that
want to cook this type of food.
AUDIENCE: Final question-- what
is your favorite, both of you,
what are your favorite
restaurants in Chicago
that you don't have
major influence,
from a business
perspective, over?
So you can't pick your own.
CHANGDRA RAM: Can I pick Bill's?
I mean, I feel like there's
so many places that--
like, there's the places that
are like the special occasion,
oh, my gosh.
Like our friends John
and Karen Shields
have a restaurant, Smyth.
They have two restaurants,
Smyth and the Loyalist.
And they're old friends
of Bill's from back
in the Charlie Trotter days.
You actually found a
good location for them.
BILL KIM: Yeah, right
down the street, yeah.
CHANGDRA RAM: But I love Smyth.
It's such a beautiful
fine dining experience,
but it's not stuffy.
It's modern and very cool.
But then they have the
Dirty Burg cheeseburger
at the Loyalist downstairs.
And that is a,
like, oh, my god, I
need something good in my life.
I'm going to go eat
that cheeseburger.
BILL KIM: So I have
to be very neutral.
So I like to go to
neighborhood restaurants.
And a restaurant that I go
to probably twice a week--
it's not even a restaurant.
It's actually takeout.
It's called Pollo
Express on 18th street.
Tuesdays and Thursdays, you
get one and a half chicken
tortillas, three different kinds
of salsa for, like 19 bucks,
like that.
And it's grilled
chicken on live fire.
That, to me, yes.
Pollo Express, and you
have to call ahead,
because they will sell out.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Pollo Express.
BILL KIM: Yes.
SPEAKER: Yes.
CHANGDRA RAM: Now I sound
like a total snob [INAUDIBLE]
BILL KIM: You are.
[INAUDIBLE] Just kidding.
SPEAKER: I think we have
one more question coming up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I think one of the things that
you were talking about in terms
of defining, almost, the type
of food or category of food,
and you hating the word
"fusion," and then people also
wanting something
super authentic, what's
that kind of balance
like, and try and find
something that's
authentic, not fusion,
but still something that's
authentic to your restaurant?
BILL KIM: Yeah.
Did I tell you I love
the word, "authentic?"
Not.
No, here's the thing--
I think everybody wants to
find that restaurant that
is like the paradise.
There is the grandmother
that's cooking.
And the rendition of the recipe
is passed on from generation
to generation.
I can't cook like that.
I have to be
authentic to who I am.
My experience in
life is not Korea.
I moved when I was seven, so
I know very little about it.
And as I grew up, my mom
would never tell me recipes.
I would go into the kitchen.
I would taste test for
her, but it was never
like she was, like,
come on, let's go.
We're going to cook.
It was never about that.
So I got my authentic
experience from the chefs
that I trained with.
And from there, me finding my
identity again, back to Korea,
because I was proud.
After I graduated
culinary school,
my mission was to cook
Asian food the best way
that I know how--
not Korean food, but Asian food.
Because that was missing.
I knew it was missing,
because after I graduated,
I wanted to find the master, the
sensei, the guy, or the lady,
that I wanted to learn
everything what they know.
And there was no such person.
And so I started finding
these little techniques
and little skills from
people that I worked for.
My business plan was to open up
that authentic restaurant that
was authentic to me.
So I'm not going to be the
[INAUDIBLE] the [INAUDIBLE],,
I can't.
I don't know how.
And that's the thing.
I make vegan kimchi.
That's not traditional.
But I know that's the best
rendition of vegan kimchi
that I know, without using fish
sauce, without using shrimp
paste, because I'm
listening to my customers.
Because they're like, well,
I can't eat shellfish.
I can't eat fish.
Why can't you do
a vegetarian one?
Well, we made it
gluten free, vegan,
and we do our best
version of that.
So is that traditional?
No, it's not.
But is it pleasing to
the general public?
Yes, it is.
So I have to listen to
how a business is run.
But I have a
conversation with my mom.
And she makes her own soy sauce.
Is that traditional?
No, she has tons of time,
so she could do that.
We cannot, so we have to buy it.
But talking to
her takes me back.
That tradition of maybe son
to father, mother to daughter,
mother to son--
I feel like I'm getting the
authentic version of what
I'm doing, because I'm
conversing with her.
I'm getting the history of why.
And from there, we do it
to the general public,
where we get to take that recipe
that maybe my mom told me,
and times it by 200, plus
by five days, six days,
seven days.
Now that recipe is 1,400
portions of whatever.
Is that traditional?
No.
It has to be commercial
enough for us
to function as a
restaurant, then go beyond.
So there needs to be a
balance of whose tradition,
and how you grew up, and
being authentic to who
you are as a person.
It hits a spot
with me, because I
can't be authentic
to my tradition,
because I was kind
of taken away.
So I have to find my own
way to discover where I am,
and what I'm cooking.
And this is what I study to do.
So this is our version
of authentic recipes
of where we are.
We do a Thai curry bolognese.
Is that authentic?
It's not, but I know
what a bolognese
is supposed to taste like.
I've made bolognese.
But why not take all the
elements of the bolognese,
and instead of using pork,
we use tea-smoked duck.
Now we have pasta that's
made with [INAUDIBLE] wine
instead of duck eggs to make it.
Is it lighter?
Yes it is.
Is it more flavorful?
I think so.
But it is our rendition
of authentic dishes
that I get basically
inspired by,
because I love Italian food.
And we put our spin on it.
So it's very hard
question to answer.
But that's the answer
that I could give.
CHANGDRA RAM: You do make the
most authentic Korean/Puerto
Rican/Italian/Thai/Vietnamese
Chicago mid-Western French food
I've ever had.
AUDIENCE: Two questions-- one
is, what's your favorite marked
if you're shopping
more for yourself,
not for the restaurant?
BILL KIM: I know
what Changdra's is.
CHANGDRA RAM: Because I live
across the street from it.
BILL KIM: Yes, you do.
CHANGDRA RAM: I live across
the street from a grocery
store called Harvest
Time, which is
one of the great
independent grocery stores.
AUDIENCE: On Lawrence?
CHANGDRA RAM: On Lawrence, yes.
But we both love
Green City Market.
Bill's been working with some of
the farmers there for decades.
BILL KIM: Yeah.
So if you want--
you got to get this experience.
Sunday about 2:30, go
to Kimball and Lawrence.
Make sure you wear pants
with bumpers on there,
because you will go to chaos,
controlled chaos at Joong Boo
Market.
It's a Korean market.
And there is no word in
Korean called, "Excuse me."
And it's just like
boom, boom, boom.
Somebody will bump
into you, and it's--
you got to have that experience.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BILL KIM: Exactly.
And the parking,
and the parking,
the attendant's like this,
and everybody's pulling out.
You got to get that experience.
AUDIENCE: OK, second question--
just given the spices
and the richness of the flavors
in Korean food in particular,
is there a particular
type or style of wine
that you found that pairs well?
or how do you approach that?
BILL KIM: I am not
a huge drinker,
but when I do different
realms of spices,
it's usually cut by sauvignon
blanc, or I like to have beer.
Ros is really good.
A margarita is also delicious.
It's really-- I spent
20 years of my life--
we would, at Charlie
Trotter, if somebody came in
to start off their
meal with red wine,
we would stop what we're doing.
Then we would have to do
a red wine menu on a dime.
So I get it.
But for me, it's
really up to you,
how you want your food to be.
And the recipe's all about that.
And if you want
to drink Kool-Aid,
or if you want to drink
Gatorade, or lemonade,
it's really up to you.
And you make that experience,
because we all do it.
Like my wife, she's very
particular about what
she drinks.
I'm just, like,
give me an ice tea.
I'll drink it with a steak, with
maitre-d' butter, and I'm OK.
It's really up to the individual
what they want to experience.
And really, it shouldn't
be about the beverage
you're drinking.
Obviously, you want it
to be, like, so perfect.
And those recommendations
with beer, the white,
and the ros is awesome.
But it's really you make
your own experience,
I think, even with the recipe.
You make it your own experience.
CHANGDRA RAM: He does say,
in the recipe for the chicken
drumsticks, that he used
to always drink Tang
with them when he was a kid.
BILL KIM: Tang.
CHANGDRA RAM: So there's Tang.
BILL KIM: Yeah, Tang.
I don't know of
Tang's around, but--
yeah
SPEAKER: It's the ideal pairing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] given
your sommelier experience?
CHANGDRA RAM:
Certainly, my experience
is not like a somm
working on the floor.
I mean, I think what Bill
said is very accurate.
I drink a lot of--
I did have to drink
while writing this book.
I really liked, also, a
lot of pinot gris, I think,
works really well
with those flavors.
Viognier, as well, something
that's very sort of fruit
forward works really
nicely with the spice.
But also, I think anything
kind of sparkling helps.
Because it actually cleanses
your palate in between bites.
So you don't get this
overload from the build-up
of all of the seasonings kind
of killing your palate there.
So when in doubt, drink a beer.
BILL KIM: Yeah.
SPEAKER: OK, well, I
have one final question.
It's a Q&A on behalf of Greg
on our Caf team for the Food
Talks program.
And just a quick plug--
today's talk is very
much a collaboration
between the Google Food
Program and Talks at Google.
And we probably will do
these types of talks just
to get folks engaged.
But one of the things
we're thinking about a lot
on the caf side is
about food waste,
and how we can reduce that,
and how we can be smarter about
maybe making something new out
of what was cooked on Monday
or whatever.
And you have an entire
chapter dedicated
to reducing food waste.
Tell us a little
bit more about that.
BILL KIM: Yeah.
I got to be very honest--
my wife hates leftovers.
After two days, she
will not eat it.
She will not touch it.
So guess what?
I always tell her that I got
this from the restaurant,
or I bought it someplace.
But it's actually redone.
I use the leftovers.
So I think it's
part of cooking that
is very underutilized,
because to me,
that's how I
learned how to cook.
You take spaghetti sauce, and
if you make more than what you
have, what do you do with it?
Do you not make spaghetti
with spaghetti sauce?
No, you could actually
make tomato soup
by adding, maybe,
a little cream,
and blending some
basil in there.
So I love cooking like that.
And the book is entirely
dedicated to that kind
of cooking.
It's not wasting, and being
able to use everything.
We don't have
bread at the house.
You know why?
Because I don't like
bread when it gets stale.
So we have rice cakes.
I eat rice cakes like
nobody's business,
because it doesn't go stale.
So I'm very practical
about how we use the food.
So when we buy a
whole chicken, yes, I
don't turn on my
stove to cook chicken.
So we buy the
rotisserie chicken.
So that turns into three meals.
So the second day, my wife
is at work, and I make soup.
And she's, like--
I'm, like, I bought soup.
Here it is.
But she doesn't know it's
from the same chicken.
Then we'll do chicken salad.
So now we're taking
that chicken so we
have three recipes out of it.
So that's how we
like to kind of not
have food waste at the house.
Cilantro is used
many different ways.
And just has to be so you can--
my wife doesn't know.
It's like we make pesto.
We use it in soups, and
sometimes I might add oil.
But it's just constant.
Even sometimes when I have
Parmesan cheese left over
from takeout, that
will go into something.
But my wife does not know.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHANGDRA RAM: But you're right.
We do have an entire
chapter in the book that's
all about how to use leftovers.
And so there are recipes
for if you happen
to have some extra
leftover chops,
or if you have extra
skirt steak, say.
And the kind of the
worst to approach
leftovers like that is to say,
I grilled this skirt steak
two days ago.
So now I'm going to
eat it the same way,
and expect that
it's going to taste
like it did just off the grill.
But you can thinly slice it.
You can toss it with some
udon noodles, and maybe
some of the Korean pesto that's
one of the recipes in the book.
And suddenly, you're
making it into something
that's totally different.
So we have recipes
that Bill created
that are all about how to
take different leftovers
from different things.
Because once you look at
grilled, leftover asparagus
sitting in your fridge, you've
got to do something to it.
Because you're not going to
just eat it the way you would
if it just came off the grill,
but mixed up in a salad, mixed
up in a sandwich, it's great.
And so we also created all
these different matrices
to help guide readers and
users so if you take a protein,
you want to add
a nice veg to it.
You want to have
some kind of starch.
And here all these different
examples, and then mix
and match whatever you've
got in your kitchen,
so you don't have to go out,
maybe, and find something
special-- that you
can pull through,
pull all of your leftovers
out of the fridge,
and create a really cool noodle
bowl, or a salad, or a grain
bowl, or something
like that based
on what you've got leftover.
So don't waste anything.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
CHANGDRA RAM: Although
Yvonne is going to kill you
after she hears this.
BILL KIM: Only Alisa
and Changdra will tell,
so I know who.
SPEAKER: So we should all
say hi to Yvonne right now.
CHANGDRA RAM: And Google.
SPEAKER: All right.
Well, everyone, thanks
so much for coming out.
Please give a warm
round of applause
for Bill Kim and Changdra.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]